how am i going to go about this
challenging task
of saying something meaningful
a distinguished place like this
on something as basic
as those two notions of power and
justice
the interaction between the two of them
and the presumed tension
between these two concepts
that to do this right one had to really
since this is going to be
an academic
institution
to really actually do a little bit of
research
go back and and read and see if you
cannot come up with this story
about the progression of those ideas
over time
what is really absolutely remarkable
having done so
was the conclusion
that how little
things have changed over that
fairly long period of time in the life
of a man
but as a matter of fact if you really go
back to before
40 years ago
and objectively look at the genesis of
human thinking and evolution of human
thinking
on those basic concepts that very much
relate
to our notion understanding of the
so-called human nature
the content of it
you'll find that very little at least
that's my own conclusion with modesty i
tell you
very little has changed
for thousands of years
coming from the region i come from
i thought it
significant to try
to relate those concepts and ideas
and the way they evolved over a period
of time
to contemporary issues in the region and
certainly
closer to home
our own issue palestinian question
exactly 42 years ago this year
right here in the netherlands
two of the most world-renowned
contemporary philosophers noam chomsky
and michelle fuku
participated
in a debate on the eternally mystifying
question of human nature
the central question of the debate was
whether there is such a thing as
innate human nature
independent of our experiences
and external influences
in other words
do we all
have something that binds us together
as human beings
in spite of our differences
but i found this debate to be
particularly fascinating
what begins as a provocative
philosophical argument
evolves into a broader discussion
encompassing a wide range of issues
including one
that is the topic of today's lecture
the struggle for justice in the realm of
political power
that is why we're here today
to explore the relationship
between power and justice and to try to
answer the age-old question
how can these two notions be reconciled
conceptually speaking we all know that
justice without power
tends to be inefficient
and that power without justice on the
other hand
results in absolutism
but what does this mean
what does it mean practically what does
it mean pragmatically in a world
where power plays a pivotal role in the
attainment of justice
we start with this question
and work our way backwards to the core
idea
of where our notion of justice comes
from do we
as human beings have an innate notion of
justice
or is this notion of justice that we all
have
a social construct
is it a product of external influences
my point in bringing up these questions
is to provide a theoretical framework
that can orient our discussion
around what we can and ought to do
practically in our own lives to improve
the human condition
understanding how power structures work
to define and administer justice is key
to understanding our rights and
responsibilities as citizens of the
world
the million dialogue
is a good springboard for the discussion
on the role of the powerful
in shaping the definition
of justice in a society
this dialogue comes from society this is
history of the peloponnesian war
which put forward the theory of
political realism
that we still use in our analysis of
world relations today
to study this rights and i could
most people seem to think shield
domination
is what is appropriate in the political
sphere
and they are not ashamed to practice in
regard to outsiders
what they recognize as neither just nor
expedient in their dealing with each
other as individuals
for their own affairs
amongst themselves there is they demand
an authority based on justice
but in regard to outsiders
justice is no concern of theirs and of
course
think about that court and how it can be
applied to the current political climate
in our part of the world
for to me
what i have just read you and out of
that court foreshadows
the very famous double-standard argument
which started to ferment in our region
as well as elsewhere in the global south
in the 60s and 70s last century
when the former colonial powers
supported regimes that in the eyes of
their their own people were unjust
never mind that our value system
stands in direct opposition
to the basic tenets of democracy
that you claim to uphold
never mind
never mind never mind
so long as we protect your global i mean
geopolitical interests again those
regimes implicitly argue so long as
we protect your geopolitical interests
why should it be any of your business
how we choose to treat our own citizens
and the west
that is the united states and western
europe
not only accords to this perverse
rationale
they were perceived by people in the
region
to be active participants in the
creation of a
suppressive political environment
that pervaded every aspect of people's
lives in the region
deferment of resentment took hold and
ultimately led to the emergence of an
ideology
that i myself
termed or described as rejectionism
youth in egypt tunisia and libya
can navigate the world through social
media
and connect with their peers in the
netherlands
in france
and the united states and realize
that they too
want to make a decent
living that they too are capable of
doing
wonderful things with their lives if
only they too
had the freedom and opportunity to do so
together with the formation mentioned
resentment rejectionism and frustration
with the status quo
this growing knowledge of what it meant
to be a citizen
with unabridged rights elsewhere in the
world
the stage was set for what followed
the stage was set
for the spark that was provided by the
self emulation of brazil in tunisia
which in turn marked the outbreak of the
arab spring
ladies and gentlemen martin luther king
once said
oppressed people
cannot remain oppressed forever
the earning for freedom eventually
manifests itself
and that is what has happened to the
american negro
but as we have seen
in the case of egypt for example and a
lot more tragically
in syria
when justice is absent for too long in a
society a revolution
at least in the short term
will likely
result
in destroying things
is more likely to result in destroying
things than building them
this has led many to mistakenly conclude
that people in our part of the world
must make a choice
between democracy
on the one hand
and stability on the other
this i believe is a dangerously
short-sighted view of the world and
history
we are no different
than citizens as well in the world
we need not
be or be seen as having to make a choice
this is a fallacy
between stability on the one hand and
democracy
on the other
in any case
we can point to many examples throughout
history
that shed light on our region's current
predicament
in this context let me point out
to place these matters in perspective
that the 1979 iranian revolution
led to a repressive islamic republic of
iran
but therefore democracy
to go back further
the french revolution of 1789
did not create a viable democracy until
three revolutions
and almost one century later
the american revolution 1776 did not
automatically produce justice
it was followed by
civil war
it was followed by an end to slavery
women's suffrage
and disaggregation which were all wrote
by struggle and sacrifice
the great 20th century revolutions
also
exemplify this pattern
the
1917 russian revolution created a
totalitarian soviet union that lasted
until after the cold war
in 1991
the 1911 chinese revolution led to the
1949 chinese revolution and more than
six decades later
china has made limited progress towards
democracy
so
our region was
to egypt for example
with its failure to rise from the ashes
of the revolution 2011 is not
just a reminder
of the tumultuous journey towards
justice but also as why justice was
necessary in the first instance
but all this teaches us is that whether
a people struggle is motivated by a
desire for an ideal
justice or a hunger for power the
absence of justice or just or even just
the general perception of injustice is
simply simply
unsustainable
at a time when so many basic democratic
tenants of our part of the world seem to
be in constant turmoil
those who had the reigns of power in the
international order world order must
uphold the universality of human rights
and the indivisibility
of justice
it is time to reevaluate their role in
guaranteeing justice for all people
of all countries consistently and
non-selectively
chomsky
makes this point in the aforementioned
debate with fuku
he says and i could
in those areas where the legal system
happens to represent not better justice
but rather the techniques of oppression
that have been
qualified in a particular autocratic
system he argues under those conditions
a reasonable human being should
disregard and oppose them end of court
that's precisely what nelson mandela did
to fight apartheid in south africa and
it's the same reasoning
that guided the civil rights movement in
the united states
i did quote martin luther king earlier
king made reference to send aquinas's
distinction between just and unjust laws
in determining the difference between
the two he said and i quote
any law that uplifts the human
personality is just
on the other hand any law that degrades
human personality is unjust
how can an individual obey a law
that reinforces his or her status as an
inferior member of society
essentially that that's what this is
about
how can we
palestinians
accept the life under occupation
when we know
that we are meant to be free
when we launched that program which
movie 194 was about state 194 was about
four years ago many dismissed it
as an exercise in idealism and maybe
those people were right in thinking
that our state building initiative
wouldn't end the occupation clearly
it has not
but despite all of that i stand here
today feeling more hopeful than ever
and the reason i say that is because it
allowed me to see firsthand the
extraordinary power of the human spirit
to achieve great many things under the
most unambiguously adverse circumstances
it got our people to think
if we could achieve all of this build
hundreds of new schools and clinics and
pave new roads
and develop new housing projects
and adequate governance structures
under a crippling occupation just
imagine what we can achieve for
ourselves once we are allowed to realize
our full potential
the idea which to me was a fully
integrated political vision and
continues to be
it was to impart a sense of possibility
to people about what we want to see
happening
in his conclusion of the myth of
sisyphus
albert camus writes and i quote
one must imagine jesus happy uncle
by choosing to live
in spite of his eternal punishment
sisyphus resists the entrapment
of victimhood
that's why he saw
sisyphus as happy
notwithstanding his predicament
that to me
is very powerful
and that's what we sought to achieve we
palestinians sought to achieve through
the act of building
our state
we are
through that active building
we were we continue to be
essentially telling the world that we
have
agency
in our liberation
it's up to us
somehow that's emancipating
that's very powerful
and it definitely does lift the spirit
the famous american historian howard
zhen once wrote
if we do act in however a small way we
don't have to wait for some grand
utopian future the future he says is an
infinite succession of presence
and to live now as we think human beings
should live
in defiance of all that is bad around us
is itself
a marvelous victory
in his letter from the birmingham jail
martin luther king reminds his
oppressors
that and i quote true peace is not
merely the absence of tension
it is the presence of justice
and of course
presence of justice and our case
requires that the fundamental asymmetry
between in in the in the balance of
power between the occupier and the
occupied be redressed
so why is all this relevant to our
discussion of power and justice
because it suggests to us
that our notion of justice is innate
it is an inherent part of our being
we may not need to be reminded
or actually in the words of martin
luther king we
may need to be reminded
that it can be gained
but we know what it looks like even if
we've been denied his virtues
these historical examples
also reveal
that justice is not only necessary to
maintain proper balance
in society but that there is an
extraordinary power that lies
in the promise of justice
indeed
it is that promise of justice
that has written
the story of human progress in my view
striving to achieve it
it is a promise of justice that empowers
the oppressed to resist senseless
violence with stubborn non-violence to
listen to their hopes instead of their
fears
to let go of their doubts and take hold
of their dreams
that is the power of justice to me
it is precisely because superiors have
the power to cultivate a definition of
justice that power needs to be checked
because the weak may acquiesce
at first
but they won't acquire us forever
our responsibility therefore as citizens
of the world is to strive to ensure that
more and more people drive power from
the promise of peaceful transformation
and justice but that requires us to
summon the knowledge
of what
binds us together in spite of our
differences
i've always wondered what our word would
look like
if it were just as easy for a rich man
to imagine what it is like to be poor
as it as it is for a poor man to imagine
what it is like to be rich
of course
i don't mean rich in the literal sense i
mean it in the more figurative sense
connoting power and privilege
maybe that's the root cause of of
injustice in our world what i call
the empathy gap
the empathy gap a subconscious and
willingness
amongst those in power to place
themselves in the shoes of the
disadvantaged
it may be precisely that lack of
understanding
of what it means
to struggle that leads the privileged
few to turn a blind eye and abandon
their responsibility to others
i believe that to whom much is given
much to be expected
we all possess that innate human
connection
but we must stop but we must tap into it
finally ladies and gentlemen
i'd like to end on this note i'd like to
assure you that we palestinians want
a lasting peace with israel
and our israeli neighbors
but we can only get to that point
if a sense of real mutual respect begins
to develop
our late poet mahmoud aleesh
once wrote and i quote
peace cannot obtain
but between equals
i know that they will come
because i do know
in my heart
that indeed
we are equal
the thought of that day
the promise of it
the promise
of the power of justice
inspires me
as i hope it does everyone
in this whole
and beyond
yes that power
the power of the promise of justice
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
thank you